by 2020 hello blaze
this kitchen's his clothes clowns missed
the playoffs again in other news let's
all hug and kiss it's day one of 2020.
mother
[Music]
hello we're the browns qbs of the past
just upset the natural order bro
you got to redo 2020 miss the playoffs
shut the [ __ ] up especially you brady
quinn i'll show the universe the browns
deserve to [ __ ] win baby so becca
fixed my knee
and now i'm still relevant this
kitchen's closed so i was thinking
actors should be in commercials not me
an undefeated season thanks to baker
benching himself and trading from a home
we spelled dog with a w every time you
restart the universe makes the year
worse the cleveland browns are to blame
for 2020. wait fits you never played for
us what
how to save the [ __ ] world we gotta
lose to the [ __ ] jets murder hornets
attack my receivers instead
annoyed should you stop dancing on logos
now the steelers are unstoppable
[ __ ] you ghosts
[Music]
pretty sure i played for the browns i
have a way of remembering
all my teams i learned it at harvard
risky biscuits bully testy triscuits
jelly bullies
donuts so that's rams bengals browns oh
we bills
bills is the second beat